[Music]
did you guys hear about dr dre
yes no his brain right everyone keeps
going i hope you feel better i don't
know what happened so he actually got
hospitalized and was sent to the icu due
to a brain aneurysm
oh
yeah so the day after he he got
announced
they got announced that he was in the
hospital there was an attempted burglary
oh timeless
which is actually quite common
apparently a lot of people they target
celebrities when they know that they're
not home
yeah so luckily no one got into the
property no one took anything
and lapd did uh
they did arrest four people wow they
were like
fully coming in yeah so the the security
at his property they did witness people
trying to like get into the property
that's why they call the cops and the
cops were able to get this
van these stupid [ __ ] they don't know
that [ __ ] rich ass
millionaires and [ __ ] have security on
their property
yeah i mean a 50 million dollar
brentwood estate we're watching um
kim on the david letterman um interview
show where it's like this
this next guest needs no introduction
and she was saying when she's
alone at home by herself that means
there's at least 12 people up
yeah i'm like holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
crazy
like even staff and things like that too
not just security right
yeah she wasn't even including like
after the the thing right after the
oh yeah yeah like now it's 12 people but
in the past it wasn't that crazy but in
the past
there's still at least like one or two
next to her all the time are you
counting kardashians too
because that would be pretty crazy yeah
that's like 50 you can't even keep up
with all those kardashians
but yeah luckily dr dre seems to be okay
so how he got it was it just like
he ate a little bit of too many oreos or
something or like
so the doctors don't know what caused it
because that's like a stroke right a
brain injury
like a bursted blood vessel yeah so it's
a it's a blood vessel that
is either inflamed or a burst and it's
very dangerous like
holy [ __ ] instead of posting this on his
instagram oh what an epic picture yeah
that is a big picture
at the hospital it says thanks to my
family friends and fans
they're going to have a studio at the
hospital no no no like he's he's at the
hospital
from the hospital he's at the hospital
he's posting it
like you you thought that was a hospital
[Laughter]
he captioned it thanks to my family
friends and fans for their interest
and well wishes i'm doing great and
getting excellent care for my medical
team i will be out of the hospital and
back home soon shout out to all the
great medical professionals at cedars
one love that doesn't even rhyme though
cedar cyanide no bars
zero bars he kind of lost touch didn't
he yeah a little bit yeah
lost it people should have commented
like man that brain aneurysm man
really messed up your rhymes bro do you
think he's used every single one of
those [ __ ] knobs like literally every
single one of them
have you seen him produce no yeah
there's like
do you all have like one of his songs
like just the beat will have over
30 tracks we'll have over 30 tracks like
per beat
how do you remember all of them like is
it like a picture like a mcdonald's
[ __ ] menu of like
i watched one video of him where he like
he goes he turns a knob
and you can't hear a single change and
he goes oh that was
it that was it and i'm like what did you
[ __ ] hear
change because i couldn't hear it dude
that's like my dad when he got the
gold-plated audio cables
from fry's electronics and he's like you
hear that [ __ ] you hear that [ __ ] and
i'm like no dad
no i don't hear and he got the more
gummies yeah but he just spent 80
dollars more
and he can't even tell either [ __ ] i
do the reverse
when uh before i had a tesla like if
anything
different sounds on my car i'm like holy
[ __ ] this whole thing's gonna [ __ ]
fall apart i don't know what that is
that sounds sounds really
bad that doesn't happen you guys no like
the reverse it sounds like you were
hearing actual sounds
yeah what do you mean the reverse like
your car like you'll hear like a
different sound and then i'm like oh my
god something's wrong with the engine
listen i like that you got to drop it
you have a tesla that was sick thank you
before i had a tesla
my car was there was [ __ ] rich now
that
you can um have for your car and there's
like a little device
and they tell you like the diagnostic
tool
yeah before you have to take it to the
mechanic
engine noise it can be like it needs
this and this and this car does that it
has little
icons that pop up but if you have like
an old car so future
it's like low tire pressure that one's
been up there for a while
fill it up girl i saw a video that's
dangerous
i saw a video where tim allen of home
improvement fame was with jerry seinfeld
and he was blindfolded
in a in a car that he'd never been in
before and it was like an older car
and tim allen knew from the sound of the
engine and from the field the inside of
the car exactly what year it was and
what making him
did you know tim allen got caught for
drug smuggling yeah
he was a drug smuggler back in the day
right he was a felon
mad weed and [ __ ] i think it was like
coke and weed and he got caught on uh
on a boat or something that's crazy yeah
imagine you're in a [ __ ] engine like
that and just knowing that [ __ ] it's
like
a thousand hours you become a master you
can hear everything you gotta be the
most bored rich guy
ever so young he's hot yeah he's a real
car guy look at that mustache
i wish i could grow a mustache sometimes
what yeah
i can good for you
why do you want a mustache because look
did you see that [ __ ]
i saw it it was like you could i want to
like do the [ __ ] i like
looks like i like to [ __ ] unicorf
myself
you should play animal crossing then
there's so many here we go
like nikki with eminem tiff brings up
animal products who's talking about
eminem oh no you said
it i just say those words i tricked
myself in animal crossing i made my
house
have an m m room oh [ __ ] and now they've
combined
forces are you happy sorry actually in
real life uh
yeah i like to fix stuff now where do
you fix what can you fix
um things that are broken the foster
stop it
like what my car like i started with the
windshield wipers
and then i started wait you mean replace
like replace it yeah replay
he doesn't have a tesla you think you
fixed [ __ ] and you just replaced your
windshield wiper blades
i buy it and then i i changed the screws
do i fix [ __ ] too i put in light bulbs i
put gas
in it bro have you seen that [ __ ]
book to like get your model the year and
then the serial number of the correct
well
that's one good point good point that's
right that's a big book
and you have to go on amazon and find
the best price or you
compare and then you shop and then you
save like 20 bucks
more street cred with saying that you
use the [ __ ] book and you took it
away by saying you went straight to
amazon
i went well he found it in the book i
went to google
okay and then i typed in the which part
i needed
and then i did that and i went to
autozone what a match
which windshield wiper is good for my
car and then the sales guy
recommended this and i bought it with my
own money and i went outside and i put
it on
did you handle with them we were like
come on man don't try not to auto zone
i feel like that story needed a lot more
and then
and then you needed that okay
and then i walked out and then i said
which one should i put on first
yeah when when dr dre
survived his aneurysm would you say that
aneurysm got
beat by dre yeah yeah i would
i would i guess so no i really thought
you were going to come up with an eminem
and i hate myself for saying that i
would dr dre eminem
well i don't see the relationship i
forgot about trey
he discovered him there we go
no but yeah so you guys know how he's in
the middle of this like crazy
contentious divorce yeah oh my god the
poor guy he's gonna get cleaned out you
got an end
exactly that's what i was saying he's a
billionaire certified billionaire right
uh i think so yeah evaluated he's gonna
get but i don't know
[ __ ] make it work dre make it work so
nicole wants two million a month in
temporary spousal support
a month and five million maintain her
lifestyle
five million for attorney fees and
but dre is saying that he's been paying
all of her expenses so the two mill
demand was
outlandish and he also says the
attorney's fees are outrageous since her
lawyers have only been working on the
case for a few months
and he also says that she's a [ __ ] yeah
like a hormonal alien you have a prenup
remember how we talked about this before
how nicole
wants a judge to reject the prenup she
signed back
and you signed the preen that you signed
but i heard that
in california it doesn't fly because she
got pressured and also because
dre ripped it up early on in their
marriage oh okay
even though that counts but dre strongly
denies ripping it out
can you just rip up a document and then
it doesn't count anymore yeah
i guess like in 1996 a speeding ticket
go
nope never sped if i break into the
smithsonian
and rip up the constitution is it like
everyone's like oh [ __ ] all right
well let's start along how many copies
did they have because if it was the hard
copy does that count
yeah there's still a digital call it
could be argued that it was a verbal
contract that he's like we're no longer
doing this contract
doesn't count i mean i guess maybe in
california does
i heard in california the prenup doesn't
really work anyway does it not
dang we got to get our assignment
somewhere else honey okay
we'll get to sign it somewhere else
because you don't even need a prenup if
you're already co-existing or whatever
for how many years then
seven years yeah you can you're kind of
married like the state sees it as that
so if you guys separate you can sue each
other
yeah isn't that crazy
messy yeah i know i i it just sucks it
seems like he's went through a lot you
know
he he's uh yeah that's what he got a
sick studio though yeah
six studios so if she takes half is he
still a billionaire no
probably not huh doesn't sound like she
wants half sounds like she just wants
two million a month so what is that
that's very reasonable long 24 yeah
for the rest of her life i hope his
income's pretty up there still
i hope so too and he's not just sitting
on a billion invested it in bitcoin
come on dude we're done pretty good we
know they didn't forget about dre right
i'm saying that he's letting nicole stay
in his
malibu mansion which he claims is worth
20 mil to 25 mil
yeah keep it [ __ ] leave me alone dude i
heard having an ex-wife is a chronic
pain
ah the chronic i'll be here all day guys
yeah that's good that's good just go all
day don't go
away they hired i agree
but yeah dre also says that his security
brings nicole meals prepared by his
private chef three to five times a week
i love he's getting petty he's gonna
start charging her [ __ ]
yeah but okay it sounds to the rest of
us
average folks that uh this [ __ ] is like
hey you're asking for too much
but when you get accustomed to a certain
standard isn't she entitled to that
lifestyle
of course i just know him and i like him
and i don't know her that's true so
let's talk [ __ ] about her yeah
because what if he was the dick face who
knows absolutely
we just don't know yeah he slapped d
barnes that's
right i totally forgot about that yeah
he did dr dre
yeah he's kind of a dick dude how crazy
that was old dre i don't know i just
don't like him because tupac didn't like
him and i like tupac more than i like
drake um
that's cool too mark wahlberg beat the
[ __ ] out of the vietnamese guy when he
was
you know when he was younger and people
still like mark wahlberg because
he i don't know he changed i know
whatever
people do change though dude some guys
are just so good at that pr [ __ ] where
they stack enough [ __ ] between that
event
yeah and like you just forget because i
like chris brown chris
you forgot about dre i did yeah that was
the fastest comeback i ever saw chris
brown
respond one yeah i mean did he really
come back though like he's still kind of
like
he did come back though he had that song
rushed it yeah yeah he totally came back
after all that yeah
all right dang i didn't know either yeah
yeah but he wasn't canceled the way
like weinstein was cancelled r kelly r
kelly uh
but i do think those two they needed to
way more canceling
i'm glad that they were cancelled did
you see the r kelly interview no
oh dude did i miss out i think he's with
gayle king and
like she's like talking to him like he's
like freaking out and you know he's r
kelly to all of us
and she's like robert robert robert have
a seat robert
and i'm just not used to hearing
somebody call r kelly like robert
something else yeah
[Music]
you